[Music]
hello there this is an interview with
the first author of the paper formal
mathematics statement curriculum
learning in which an automated system
was able to solve two problems of the
international mathematics olympiad now
this is an unprecedented level of skill
in formal mathematics for an ai system
the system uses language models in
combination with a technique called
expert iteration to build itself a
harder and harder curriculum of theorems
to prove now if you haven't seen it i've
made a comprehensive paper review about
this paper in the last video so be sure
to check that out because stan the
author who i'm interviewing today has
seen that video so we all start from a
common level stan is able to directly
respond to any criticisms and questions
that i had during the paper review and
we go into the details into the behind
the scenes of the research what didn't
work out what problems came up how the
project came to be and what this all
means beyond the domain of mathematics
it is a huge privilege to have the
authors of these papers on here and i
want to get the most information that i
can out of them so please let me know
how i can improve these videos let me
know in the comments leave a like if you
like and i'll see you around bye
all right everyone hi today i'm here
with stan polu who is the first author
of the formal mathematics statement
curriculum learning of the paper that
uses expert iteration to end up proving
two imo problems which i think was was
very
well received
by everyone in the community and we're
gonna look at the paper i'm gonna go
maybe through some of my criticisms that
i had and that i just threw out there
and yeah we're gonna have uh we're gonna
hopefully inform everyone a little bit
more stan welcome to the channel
thank you thank you very much for for
having me uh it's a real pleasure to be
here
um so this this obviously the paper it
helps that open ai is as a name on the
paper right it gives it like a little
bit of a boost in publicity but still it
was the reception was quite widespread i
want to say even though it appeared i
think in the same week as some other big
papers like i think alpha code was in
the same week or so uh yet still you
made quite an impression on people
and
do you
have an idea of of why sort of the paper
was
was widely received there have been
other papers in this domain but this was
kind of special what's your impression
yeah uh so so first yeah you mentioned
that i woke up in the eye just to give
you a little bit of context uh so i'm a
research engineer at open ai
openai is focused on building and
deploying safe and beneficial ai systems
it's a little bit
part research lab and part deployment
company and i myself focus on the
research lab part
the release was actually
um the same day as alpha code uh we we
actually decided to to go for it
right after the release network and i
think it's uh it was it was just fine
um
we did release the first paper before uh
the the first gtf paper which is
referenced from from that paper uh a
year ago and it did dive it didn't have
that much support from open eye because
it was kind of a
kind of a
shadow release we just put the paper up
there with other blog posts and it did
have quite a lot of
it did bring quite a lot of interest as
well i think people are
interested in in the domain because uh
mass seems like a frontier that we
haven't reached yet and so any progress
in that direction seems is probably
exciting to
most of the people in the community that
would be my kind of main
understanding of as to why people
reacted positively and are engaging with
the work
so you were already in this domain you
said and and i think i've also commented
on this a little bit you had previous
previous work in using language models
to guide these these provers was this
sort of
a natural continuation for that or
was there some impulse behind you
tackling um sort of these more
challenging problems
yeah so it's a it's really a
continuation of the previous work and
actually to give you a little bit of a
of of color on all of that i i joined
open ai two years ago and i actually
wanted to work on formal mass and ai
before i joined open eye and i did have
quite an
original trajectory within the field um
i i don't have a phd in machine learning
i don't have a phd at all actually and i
was uh actually a software engineer at
stripe before and eventually wanted to
work on subjects that that pertain to ai
and decided that uh formal maths was the
the things that i wanted to work on and
then
uh found that
it was well aligned with open-air
emission and the way we were executing
it and so i joined and shortly after i
started working on it so i'm actually
been working on this for the last two
years
uh and the that paper is real
continuation of the first paper and it's
just kind of a a real continuous work
that we're tackling and i think we'll
we'll definitely continue working on
that because those two ammo problems are
quite impressive
but uh but we're still far away from
being uh at best students level
it is to some extent mine
it's to some extent it's mind-blowing
because
that that system can prove
statements that i'm actually myself not
capable of proving i'm not a mass
competitor but i did do quite a lot of
math uh
studying
for engineering school in france
and there are some things that i just
can prove and that this system can prove
but at the same time there's so many
stuff that i find easy and this kind of
proven so we we're still
a long a long way
away from
being being able to be at a best human
level but still those progress have been
really continuous and continuously
exciting over the past two years
do you you've seen my
explanation of the paper
and i think with this paper specifically
i'm not that much of an expert in the
domain itself so i'm not into
not too much into formal math and these
sort of proving algorithms how provers
even work i've tried to
explain that a little bit by building
this this proof tree right here do you
maybe have any
more more comments any insights that
could help people understand you know
what is formal math even
like how does it look from the inside
like what is what is the main problem
how do you do things there
of course uh to be honest you you really
need the explanation it's uh it's it was
really clear and i think it's a really
good explanation of what's happening
uh formal mass was kind of invented when
computers came out right
the main problem that it tries to solve
is that when you have a mass paper and a
very impressive proof you only have
generally a few people in the world that
can review that proof because those
proofs are generally so complicated that
only a few people can just understand
those right
and so
there's actually no way to be sure that
those massive proof
are
indeed true and that's kind of annoying
because we're talking about mathematics
supposed to be you know rock solid uh
yet it's it's not the case because those
subjects are so advanced and so the
motivation for fall mass is to say well
let's uh actually encode mass
for computers such that computers can
check every step
and we're gonna
get rid of that problem and forever be
confident in our math
progress
the only caveat is that because we need
to to i mean people working in formats
needs to
reformat the proof in a way that
computers can pass
despite a lot of automation that helps
in that process it's still a very very
very time consuming effort
and so the the advance of formalization
of mass concepts has been lagging behind
the state of the art in mass
tremendously
but it's still starting to to pick up
especially in lean where we've seen some
recent formalization of very advanced
and new and new work but the main
the main problem of formal math i think
is that it's really hard to formulate
and so
what is formalized formulization like
it's exactly as you stated you you
basically state your your statements uh
stating statements once you have the
right definitions is almost natural it
feels a bit complicated when you look at
the statements from the paper as you
mentioned but it's actually close to
what you would write in english but then
the proof is really
completely different because you really
have to to to
contrive it in a way that the computer
can understand and the way it works is
as you mentioned it's really an
interaction between the human and the
machine you have that first statement
which is your goal you apply some
tactics which are the automation i
mentioned to try to help in the
formalization so you generally provide
some direction to tactics and tactics
are meta programs that are taking your
directions and trying to generate proof
terms which are much lower level
artifacts that are understood by the
machine so the bridge between the human
and the machine and you keep going like
that
you know you generally know the informal
proof of course you generally have to
change it in
non-trivial ways to make it
probable with all the series you have
available and the constraint of the
formal system and eventually you can
keep making progress like that with
trial and error so you have the feedback
from the formal system which are your
current goals and you try and make
progress this way until you as you
mentioned you reach something that you
know is true because it's already been
proven or it's an axiom or it's an
hypothesis
do people you mentioned you mentioned
right now that people formalize by
already sort of knowing the proof from
the math domain maybe do is there is
there
are there people that seriously prove
things for the first time in the formal
way or is it largely just a translation
effort because i'm wondering uh the way
your your system works in in proof
searching and this is not necessarily
this paper alone but it seems to me
proof searching what it does is it
simply traverses the tree of of all
possible kind of like a chess engine or
so um would do something like this and
i'm wondering if that if you think that
is similar to how humans uh try to go
about proving mathematical concepts or
is there some fundamental difference on
how the machine does it and how the
humans do it
uh there are some in my opinion there
are some similarities and some
massive difference um
if if
if you know what the proof is already
it's really
it looks like a little bit like a
translation exercise uh but one that is
quite challenging because you really
have to generally refactor the proof
in non-trivial ways as an example
uh peter trolls with a very well-known
mathematician uh came to the formal
community and said i have that that new
proof that i'm super excited about but
it's kind of complicated and i want to
make sure that it's true
please help me or please formalize it so
that we can
know for sure
and that effort it's a it's a kind of uh
you know
ten thousand of page phd of math right
so it's not that big
and i think therefore took six months
old a bit more to
dozens of people
uh so
it's not just translation because
generally you have definitions that are
missing and so you need to you need to
add them you need to create a series
that are missing etc so it's a very
complicated look
um and so that's that's one of the main
difference between what we're doing and
what the mathematics should do actually
uh today we are really focusing on
proving theorems at fixed theories in
the sense that we're tackling
olympiads problems for which we know
that all the theorems and the diffusions
that we'll need are already proven in
the formal system in a sense
but when a mathematician is doing his
job he's not spending his day proving
stuff what does mathematician do
most is actually coming up with new
definitions new objects finding
correlate i mean finding a link between
those definitions and those domains and
that's something that we're actually not
tackling at all today
really focusing on trying to solve
exercise yeah
rather than creating new theories and so
the the the main thing is essentially
knowing which tactic do i need to apply
uh to sort of to sort of use the
existing theorems that i have or the
existing concepts that i have in order
to to prove the particular statement
um you you have you say there are two
main problems right here so there's
first is this infinite action space um
thing uh and you
and this can be solved by having this
search be guided by
whatever language model you use i mean
people i think know this from
uh alpha zero type algorithms right
where we use some sort of a neural
network to guide that search and this is
already a little bit in your previous
work but then the other thing you
mentioned is no you have no direct
self-play setup which obviously is very
helpful in these types of automated
things in these search procedures if you
have like some adversary that's playing
against you and both get better at the
same time and i've mentioned here you
make a statement that says um
this paper focuses on the second problem
our basis for addressing it is the
observation that the key role of
self-play is to provide an unsupervised
curriculum and the statement just kind
of stands here
as such you kind of claim this uh do you
want to comment maybe a little bit i
mean it seems intuitive right uh but how
do you arrive at this conclusion
so it's it's it's indeed more of an
hypothesis than a than a strong
statement i i totally admit and agree um
i we have some experimental evidence
that uh if you if an ex actually if i'm
if
if you if you think of alpha zero it's
actually what's happening but basically
if you take all the data that has been
generated through a training loop of an
alphago type uh algorithm if you take
the final data set and train on it
you'll get the same performance as if
you've been
training
sequentially basically
and so
there is nothing kind of special in uh
self-play
episodes basically it's more about
generating the right data at the end and
so it's and i think it's not just about
the difficulty it's just about creating
a lot of diverse data that explores the
space quite nicely
and that's kind of stems from having a
player against which you're playing and
by exploration you deviate a little bit
and find new strategies that are
interesting and eventually all that if
you accumulate all that you train on
that you get a very good policy of our
function
and i think that's that's why we say
this is that the the the self-play that
we have in two-player games is is really
about getting a data generation pipeline
that generates good data right
um and and that's why we call it a an
unsupervised curriculum and in formal
maths you
if you have a statement a bunch of
statements that you cannot prove because
your program is just not good enough
you're just not going to get any data
it's going to be you're going to just be
stuck at that point
and so that's kind of the main
difference there is no
way to reframe i mean there's no trivial
or easy or obvious to me at least ways
to reframe a problem that is just too
odd into a set of easier problems yes
and this it makes sense that you're
trying to build up curriculum but now
also i've displayed this here with this
sort of arrow of complexity that just
gets more and more complex but it is not
really the case it doesn't really look
like this because
complexity isn't just in one direction
it's not just a statement is more
complex than another one but there is
there's also a direction i wanna i think
if i want to work myself up to prove
let's say the whatever general riemann
hypothesis or something like this i
can't just you know prove harder and
harder statements in uh numerics or
something because i really want to be in
i don't even know what category the
riemann hypothesis number theory or
complex
analysis okay
you know but the point is i can't just
go about just proving any old you know
theorems um
i have to have some sort of a
a direction so how how does how does
your and you make a little bit of a
point in you know manual curation might
help here and so on but is what's the
main force in your system
driving sort of the direction that the
system becomes an expert at because
there's so many directions in math right
it's impossible that it just becomes
better right
yeah
so
i mean we took the
very obvious and easy way uh basically
you have in a with a formal system you
have a library of crms that is actuated
with it that's what what the formal
community generally working on this is
what we call math lib it's called mass
living lean
and there is very few exercise or
olympiad type exercise or even exercise
in my sleep it's generally a general
purpose here right
and so
you should train on that data only uh
you're actually not that good at solving
exercise because you haven't seen any uh
the very easy exercise you'll be able to
solve but the somewhat hard ones not
involved and so and we had that mini f2f
benchmark which is made of exercise that
we had exercise that we cared about for
many reasons that we can dive into
um and so we took the easy dizzy
the easy way which is
let's just formalize a bunch of
statements around that that benchmark
that we care about and
we we did the most obvious thing is that
we took the textbook that humans used to
train for those competitions
and formalize
everything out of it
and didn't i mean we didn't ask
ourselves much more questions than that
and the the reason why it works is
because
it's a textbook so there is a bunch of
easy examples to begin with and the
difficulty can have been proved nicely
for for humans
and so
as we we formalize the statements we run
the our expat situation loop on it and
as you mentioned in that in that
illustration you get a few statements
first but you retrain on them so you get
a few more etc etc and as you do it to
really uh the way i visualize it is that
you're really shifting the distribution
of the model
away from math leave and towards mini
f2f or towards the group of statements
that you provided as a as a curriculum
and so that is that creation that gives
the direction
um
in terms of direction it's a you're very
right that it's a it's a challenge
something that you can do as an example
with formulas is you can do forward
proving instead of going backward as you
said
you take things that you know and try to
compose them with crms that you that
that unify to the things you know and
you keep going forward like that and
we've tried generating some data this
way
and
that data is is actually
not i mean you cannot direct it
easily and so it goes a little bit all
over the place
and it's and we haven't found a way to
to make it uh uh uh
i mean to make it beneficial for for for
targeting a benchmark in particular that
we care about
do you see maybe a future where uh
you you mentioned the lack of self-play
but there could be some sort of an agent
that comes up with these intermediate
statements these these curriculum
statements that sort of tries to guess
you know maybe here is a statement
that's kind of in between uh where you
want to go and where you are currently
uh this this could be
some sort of i mean it
i'm never sure because a lot of times
when people propose these agents it's
like well you if you have that agent
you've essentially solved the problem
right but there there could be some
sort of thing that replaces you the
human as
who has to come up with this curriculum
but i guess it's a bit of a future thing
and the the other
avenue where i see sorry sorry i i i i'd
like to uh to just
jump on this one uh just just for a
second
um
it is it is plausible that we could
build a model i mean it's theoretically
plausible that we could build a model
that creates those intermediary
statements uh there's two challenges
here is the first one is that the number
of statements that we have is actually
extremely small when you look at the
proof data in form or mess and i didn't
mention it before but it's also a good
thing to mention it's one challenge of
all math is that data is extremely
scarce the proof data is scarce and the
statement data is even scarcer uh
mass sleep is something like 60k 60k
statements it's
context lens things
uh the curriculum we use is a few
hundreds and so to train the agents to
try to simplify statements the data that
you have access to is
like in existence by standards
modern language modeling standards
so that's a really big challenge
one thing that i think is extremely
exciting that is again same idea just
make it simpler is probably
actually machine translation from
informal statements to formal statements
exactly the work that we've been doing
try to harvest a lot of informal
statements that there are many more out
there
and try to auto formalize them
formalizing a statement is actually much
easier than formalizing a proof it's
still changing but definitely much
easier and no no no sorry for dropping
in so with respect to yeah i was i was
also thinking
yeah you could you could take all sort
of the math that's that's out there but
yeah that's obviously also curated by
humans a little bit um
it the other point of controlling things
would be the language model there's a
lot of there's a lot of um
work in prompt engineering and things
like this now your language model maybe
we can go a little bit into how you
train and query the language model which
i think might you know might need or
might um benefit from a bit more
explanation because i was i was quite
vague here right but essentially you
have two different types of inputs that
you train the language model on the one
you call this uh proof step objective
and the other one you call this proof
size objective and both of them they
have a
a declaration and a goal uh do you want
to maybe give us a little bit because
for the declaration i was like yeah it's
it's kind of like the things you have
access to do you want to maybe give us a
bit of insight into what these things
are
yeah so
uh if we go back to uh if we think about
your your
schema about proving backwards uh so the
goal is the current goal that you want
to prove the proof step uh is the tactic
that you want to apply so this is really
mapping exactly the process of
generating a tactic to try to
synchronize sorry the goal so if i'm
here right um
the goal would be the top thing this one
right here
and the tactic would be one node one
link to to a sort of the next node
okay two new but then you could go this
would be the new goal and then
these could be the proof steps
or
okay okay yes exactly in your in your
here the the lines are the tactics uh
and the the circles are the goals and in
lean you actually
in line you actually have just one goal
a tactic goes back to another goal
because sometimes some tactic can create
multiple sub goals but because you could
say hey i want to introduce that cut a
cut is kind of a
mini conjecture inside a proof
and but but lean kind of stacks them
together so technically speaking uh
there's only one like node
at each end of each line
okay
yeah exactly the proof looks like a
chain a proof proof the final proof
looks like a chain okay
and the proof search looks like a tree
and so the uh the the decal uh with
condition on the decal name so the decal
name is the declaration name and it's uh
simply the crm name or the exercise name
and the uh
the motivation here is to provide a
proxy information for the model
as to what is the state of the formal
environment at this stage
because the actual formal environment is
gigantic
there's no easy way to represent it in a
compact way
you have all the imports you have
all the serums that have been defined in
the same file before that very serum
that the serum you're trying to prove
right now you have a bunch of
definitions etc and so the if you wanted
to represent that to the model it's
technically challenging and more
importantly it's it's really big
so instead we just give it the name of
the crm and we kind of uh hope that
it'll provide signal as to to the model
as to what are the
serums that it has access to for this
one
because it's trained it's trained on on
serums that are close to this one and
the names of serums are somewhat similar
and related it was in the same file etc
etc so it's really kind of a trick to to
try to infuse a little bit of
information about the environment isn't
such a name is this like a human
readable name or is this more like you
know theorem two eight four five point
eight
no no
it's somewhat uh
readable for the uh for the experts at
least uh
it's inter floor
smaller than
floor positive some kind of
stuff like that it's it's a little bit
compact but it's still readable
and for the exercise that we use it's
actually just the name of the
competition the girl and the exercise
number and the the proof step that will
be
the tactic itself how is a tactic kind
of described is this an index into some
bucket or is it also a piece of text or
yeah so if you scroll in the appendix
well i i describe it uh the uh tactic is
really uh a function call you're calling
the tactic which is a meta program so if
you uh yeah as an example this one apply
technique is
very trivial it just says try to apply
that theorem to the current goal
but you have much more advanced uh
tactic and so that tactic takes an
argument so you not only have to pick
your tactic there's only a few of those
but you you actually have to provide an
argument so here it's a serum name
uh there's many more but it's still
finite this here is a theorem and then
you will uh
oh yeah yeah there you go prime and dv
okay not prime i see dvd
yeah
so that's a that's a typical scenario so
that's the declaration name that we
conditioned on if we wanted to try to
prove it
and you have to apply it with uh here
it's supplying the serum by providing a
first argument to the crm
and then looking at the one side only
and so all of that kind of explodes the
the the action space obviously and the
action space is actually infinite
because some tactic tech has arguments
mathematical terms and those
mathematical terms they
don't necessarily exist in the context
if you uh if you're trying to uh to
prove an existential statement uh often
the easiest way is to provide a witness
uh the witness is not generally in the
statement
and so you have to generate it and so
that's the reason why the action space
is actually infinite and that's the
major difference between
neural
proving techniques
and the kind of classical
theorem proving or automated reasoning
techniques they are extremely powerful
but there's one thing they cannot do
it's generating
exogenous mathematical terms and you
would you would in this case your
language model would directly suggest
you such tactics to apply so you would
sample from the language model and then
exactly suggest a bunch of things yep
the language
generates the full
string here apply knight prime w hp mp
and so we generate a number of those
that gives us that kind of gives us an
approximation of a potential interesting
action space to explore and on top of
that we run and then how does the proof
step come into this because i was a
little bit you already have some sort of
a log likelihood estimation i would
guess for the things that you sample but
then you also have this um this value
some sort of a value
that you assign to how long you think a
proof is going to be
yeah so the proof size objective takes
the declaration name and the current
goal and try to estimate the
size of the proof for that goal
and that's really just
an instance of a value function that's
the one that we've used here
and it really helps guiding the proof
search
when you don't have the value function
yet so in your review you mentioned that
we bootstrap from theta0 which is the
first model that is on train on proof
steps when we don't have a value
function to to available we can what we
do is that we we do the same proof
search but we prioritize by log probe as
you said but what we use is the
cumulative log probe
that
took for us to apply the different
tactics all the way to the current goal
which is another
bit of a beam search type that is uh
yeah
yeah it's a beam
depth search
okay um and okay so i think we got a
good idea of how the how the search
itself works and you you keep going
until the approve statements and then
you do this expert iteration steps right
which essentially consists of you try to
prove new things you add them back to
the data set and you train a new model
on it was i what i was kind of uh
surprised by is that you always train
from this sort of this initial model
that you have right here so you create
your new data sets and you always train
from that what prevents you
or you know what's the reasoning behind
not always just continuing to train from
the most recent model
yep there's uh two motivations two
rational for that the first one is that
it makes controlling for the fits much
easier um
because you're really training from
scratch in a sense and so you control
overfit on your validation set much more
cleanly if you iteratively train the
behavior of your the validation loss i
have the tendency to be quite erratic
and unpredictable which makes
controlling for the fit much less
obvious so that's the one thing it's for
basically scientific convenience in a
sense
um the other thing is that it gives us
an opportunity to duplicate aggressively
the data
uh the reason why it's important it's
because to be honest to generate those
proof with sample uh proof search a lot
there are some the easy statements we
can find thousands of different proof
for it
and so the goal is to retake all those
proof that we found so far and
deduplicate as much all of it to
prevent kind of nefarious overfitting
behaviors in the training
so that's really the two main motivation
for train from scratch again formal mass
um
data is scarce so those data sets are
not that big uh even when we generate a
lot of data and so training is not
taking that much time so it's actually
really fine to train from scratch at
each iteration and um
you so
one second
uh
sure
so
i was
you you say you you have easy statements
you're able to find a lot of proofs for
them you have hard statements and you
know that's difficult to reach but you
still said at the beginning
all the statements you are attempting to
prove you essentially already know that
they're provable right and even the the
ones in the curriculum
um the ones you take from the textbook i
think textbooks they don't try to trick
you with like exercises that ultimately
don't really work out um how would you
what would change here if you were to go
about proving some something you don't
know
if it's even provable right obviously
also don't know the statements in
between that might lead up to that like
how would that how would that look like
uh to prove something that isn't proven
yet
okay so i think there's two questions
there there's what would happen if you
inject statements that are that that are
potentially false or even undefeatable
uh in the in the in the mix
and what what would it take to try to
prove something that we don't really
know is probable yet i think uh so
that's at least the way i understood the
question
if we inject statements that are not
provable that are false or undecidable
uh same difference
uh to us at least in the context of one
formal system um
the um what happens is that nothing
happens there's no data generated so
you're just wasting compute you're
really just waiting compute on the
statements
and that's going to be a challenge if we
think back about automatizing or
automatizing the uh
generation of statements
that's going to be a noisy imperfect
process and so whether it's going to
it's going to be a useful uh for uh that
expat iteration process is really a
function of the uh number of statements
that are actually provable versus
unprobable if your automated translation
system generates one out of 20
statements that is profitable and and
nine and you know 19 are unprovable
you're just going to be wasting a lot of
computes trying to prove something
that's not going to generate any data
for you so that's going to be a
challenge there if we want to apply
machine translation
and then um
proving something what do you mean by
proving something that well let's say
you you want you want is it like trying
to control you wanna train or you wanna
solve a conjecture that exists but no
one no one knows we think it's provable
right which we do with most conjectures
but no one knows and now it's up to you
and you and someone comes to you and say
well you know let's use your system like
how would you go about that how would
you build the curriculum what would
change maybe in the data collection yep
so
there's
so there's
there are some conjectures that we can
hope
do not require inventing new mass
so there may be some conjecturing there
there are some contractors that are
eluding humans um despite being very
close to us it's just we're just one
trick away
and so if if such for such conjecture
and imagining a system that is
much more powerful than what we have
today let's say it beats you man at
competitions
then you could just
take your best system take the
conjecture and search for a lot of time
right and you maybe have a hope
of finding a proof that has eluded
humans because it was really tricky but
you didn't need new theorems you didn't
need new definitions
and for most of conjectures
that are out there there is good reason
to believe at least if we look this
directly that they're going to require
new mathematical concepts to be
proved
and so that's exercise which is the
mathematician's exercise of defining new
concepts is something that we
even i'm not even considering yet as a
as a problem it's a whole different
problem and to be honest i think that
it's a it's a it's a task
that has
that will probably
more likely happen in the future
in the informal realm more than in the
formal realm it feels like the informal
realm seems to be a better space to try
to come up with new concepts and maybe
then we have good auto formalization and
then we can use a formal proverb to
prove all the things that we contracted
etc but that's something that is really
far away you think you could you could
sort of abuse the language models maybe
to go a step
let's say further um you always have
your declaration and your goal and you
generate the proof step could you also
maybe just input a declaration of a
theorem name that you think you know
might conceivably exist and then let the
system come up with a goal by itself
even so like even the statement to be
proven
uh we've tried that uh definitely works
you can uh you can let the model
generate
generate goals that are valid
and that can then
uh you can even
orient with all
talking about how do you orient your
your
your work towards stuff that interests
you you can definitely in that that's in
that case you can definitely prompt the
model
where you're interested to explore by
the declaration name you can make up
kind of funky names that look like
analysis or funky names that look like
group theory or even funky names that
look like math olympiads and the the
model will definitely and gladly
conjecture
statements and it's actually
conjecturing all the time in a way that
is not leverageable unfortunately
when we do proof search
when we do proof search the way we refer
to crams that exist is best is by
declaration name not by the statement
themselves in lean at least and so all
the time every proof search the model
will just invent
serum by name
that and the name look really legit uh
they should be in mass sleep actually
because it's just a missing api because
it the name
we know it's generally very
interpretable what the model think
should be there
and so that kind of contractoring
behavior really exists uh in in the
model today and and and is probably
leverageable
it's interesting it's crazy because that
is really how i think you know
mathematicians go about proving
something is like they say you know
they're at some statement then they say
uh well here i need i need like some
inequality that relates these two things
to each other and
essentially that is exactly coming up
with like a name of a theorem like this
that the name would be something like
you know in
this greater than this or
it's crazy i mean yeah i'm
yeah
so yeah we we actually can prove we can
extract from math sleep the uh what we
call the uh
basically the type elaboration so type
elaboration is you take a name of the
theorem and you
infer the type and the type is in in
type theory the type is the statement
itself
and so we can train models and type
elaborations so we could have them
conjecture names while the proof search
and then take the name and try to type
elaborate them that gives us a statement
and then try to prove that statements
that's something we haven't expected
it sounds i mean it sounds crazy and i'm
you know given just the directions of
these systems of these automated systems
that can essentially generate data from
them for themselves if you introduce
something like this i'm i'm pretty
convinced this can get us a whole lot
further i mean how fast have these go
and chess algorithms become
they've become human and like one month
later they were totally superhuman like
it just it happened like like in an
instant which is crazy um yeah
my question would be a little bit
this is a machine the formal machine you
have the humans on the other side is
there a good way of the two working
together like is there some sort of
because it seems like they have
complementary skills one can like search
and and and you know try to prove things
very quickly the other one maybe has
more
more of that idea like introducing new
math and so on is there a tight way
where the two can work together or will
it always be in the well we have to
translate sort of from one domain to the
other
so another
definitely way um we actually released
our early models it was almost a year
ago to the lean community through a
tactic that is called gptf and so
formalizer could say gpdf and gpf would
answer with
suggestions of things to try
um and it's it's it's it's broken and
clunky in many ways um and there's a
technical challenge which is that the
the mass library advances every day it's
the models you have to are kind of easy
to they can rot quite rapidly
for research purposes it's very
convenient for us to just say for the
next three months we're gonna walk on
that commit and just not look at what's
happening out there
but yet if you want to provide value to
the community you have to stay fresh
which is a more of an engineering
challenge than anything else but it's
definitely a plan to provide or models
to the community the
most and and it's to be honest that's
the i mean anybody working on form of
math and ml think about that that just
makes sense right
uh because formalization is so it's not
that hard but it's time consuming and so
if all models can speed up formalization
by
an order of magnitude that would be just
tremendous and right there there's
already a very nice
symbiosis as you say
because if we speed up formulation by
10x or by 2x even by two weeks uh people
will formalize much more stuff
and we'll get much more data and we'll
get better and that's a loop that goes
through uh actually people committing
stuff to matlab and us injecting it back
eventually so it's kind of a long a very
uh long loop but it's a loop that we we
plan to try to set up
yeah i mean this it would be i think
that would be
sort of the
the best case outcome right here that
there is like the symbiosis of of just
uh the machine helping the humans and so
on before it eventually will outperform
them and make mathematicians useless
so we're far away from that anyway
maybe last technical question from my
side uh it seems like in such an
iteration process you said for example
you know we can the easy statements we
can find thousands of proofs for them
and you do some deduplication right to
to sort of reduce the number of proofs
if two proofs are equivalent you take
the shorter one which is you know very
sensible but still
uh how do you avoid that most data that
you add back to the data set is kind of
useless because
uh given given like three basic facts a
mathematician can probably prove 16
things right and and only very few of
them are going to be valuable to advance
towards my my ultimate goals like how
how do you make sure that what you add
back to the data set actually has
some sort of uh value to the to the
expert iteration
so uh the explosion of of of statements
and proof that uh that goes into a lot
of noisy and interesting and interesting
stuff generally it comes when you do
forward proving if you do backward
proving you're really bonded by the
statements you're trying to prove so you
might find
thousand different proof for something
easy and all the thousands are
they vary just because um the model
decided to name a variable differently
and so they're not that interesting and
there we have much more work to do into
having smarter duplication
uh
but
really um
in a sense
because and that's the main advantage of
working on formal mass because we
that data has been verified by the the
formal system we know it's legit it's
one
key
massive advantage that we have to do to
explore interesting research ideas
compared to other domains is that we can
lean on that verifier to
really make sure that we only use
legit
data even if it's as the model that
generated it and that's uh i think
that's that's that's key here and
generally speaking empirically um
it's it's it's always felt like
the training basically greater gradient
distance is is about compression and and
the training process is actually good at
sifting through repetitive and not
necessarily repetitive but
somewhat similar data and so having a
lot of
different proof is actually generally
beneficial against the story of people
learning
the more the more the better
whatever whatever it is
is there anything i've not gone too much
into the into the results other than
saying you know
the expert iteration obviously helps you
uh to prove much harder statements
compared to just the solver whether you
are just for compute or not it's also
interesting that you know the um
yeah so so larger models whenever you
you scale up stuff essentially you get
better right um is there anything in the
experimental results that maybe i
haven't touched on that you would like
to highlight specifically
well i think you you really uh you
really covered uh it well uh one one
result that i think you almost touched
on one question and that is unanswered
in the paper is uh we we do include the
synthetic inequalities in the final
experimental setup to target mini f2f
and uh and actually i've run the
ablation of that and they don't they
don't help that much on mini f2f quite i
mean
it's not that much that's surprising so
it's really if you remove them and and
plot the curves for uh against the f2f
you really get somewhat sensibly similar
stuff
um
we
we there is a few inequalities that have
been solved that are challenging
and
it's it's always a challenge because the
graph tells you that it's roughly the
same but then when you look at the proof
you feel like it's been learned through
the curriculum and scientific
inequalities so that's the reason why we
kind of uh we kind of kept it here and i
think it does unlock a few problems but
it does it's kind of
a few problems at the margin so it's
it's hard to to make sure by just
looking at averages
and
one interesting
thing of course is as you say you scale
your compute whether you scale in model
size or your scale in number of attempts
in a scale in depth of search you always
get better it doesn't really seems to be
and i i mean it's true of of of
most of recent deep learning uh there
really seems to be uh
performance
being really a function of of computes
that you efficiently pour into the model
uh pour into the system
um
though we've been very surprised many
times that model size scaling is hard to
leverage
we know those larger models are so much
smarter when you interact with them
directly you ask questions with gp3 it's
it's qualitatively better than gpt2
right
um and here we are at the gpt 102 kind
of size
and so
common wisdom would say
one or two
just dumb right so why not use jupiter's
size because we're talking about mass
and uh really um what we've seen
empirically and that's it's probably and
and potentially because of bottlenecks
in our setup that we haven't yet
correctly identified but is that you
don't need to have that big of a model
to to be efficient and it's actually
actually detrimental to scale the modded
size because then your proof search
becomes much more compute intensive
and in terms of flux allocation it's
much more efficient to sample many more
times from smaller models
it tells something quite interesting it
tells that the smaller model is
is is um
basically is not completely it is not
much less mass than a larger model it's
just that the distribution is not as
crisp
and here because we have the verifier
and we can sample many times we can
juice
the good samples out of a small model
by trying many times yeah maybe that
becomes it's only because we have a
verifier you go to like more like really
hard math statements maybe at some point
you really need sort of the the large
models but who knows
um is there yeah
was there
i'm a bit interested also in the process
of the research itself you know seeing a
final paper is always really nice and
cool and wow you get to you know your
model does all this thing uh was there
like particular low points during the
research as well like particular moments
where you think
uh this isn't gonna work out after all
or things like this um any any you any
you would like to share maybe so that
other people you know it helps to
identify
because i think most people find
themselves into spots in spots like that
yes definitely
um
to be honest i've been quite i mean
we've been quite lucky with that project
in the sense that there's been some low
points but
at any point of time looking back three
months
uh
in the past we always felt like we we
had made good motivating progress over
the the those three those three months
uh but it's obviously been a lot of
struggles at many times i think research
at least the way i i see it is a lot of
about struggling
uh for quite some time on some problems
that's the reason why you really want to
care about the problem you're working on
to to kind of be able to go through that
struggle it's actually the same as
startups in a sense you really have to
care enough to be able to go through the
struggle
and
to give you an idea we really i mean
i i started walking alone we we there's
no multiple people working on the
project with me but when i started i
really took a language model and i took
a a data set of tactics uh that i that i
exported from it was metamask at the
time
and nobody had any idea whether a
language model was capable of generating
a tactic because the syntax was so
precise we were talking about
interacting with the formal system there
were no cogent results at the time
um
sorry congeneration results at a time
and so it really was an open question
whether a language model is good enough
to generate formal
synthetically formal
sentences in a sense and so the first
one was really that it's like
not only you you train your model and
start sampling and you just look at your
sequence accuracy and you you see that
it's not zero and it's right there it's
a it
doesn't prove anything and it's far from
being able to prove anything but it's a
massive win you're like yes language
models can
generates kind of synthetically uh
formal statements
so that was really the the start
um
i think the uh leading to the first
paper the first gtf paper the two key uh
uh moments where okay let's try to scale
the model size uh and uh and and seeing
that scaling is really beneficial it was
kind of it's not as we discussed
kind of
not as clear but if you're just looking
at performance in terms of model size
you see that very nice scaling if you
don't adjust the compute basically and
so that's something that is quite
motivating and exciting because you know
it's kind of the trend of the the domain
in many
effects
and uh the uh the key as the key also
finding of the first paper that was
really a motivation to continue walking
was that pre-training and we you chatted
you talked about that in the
in the review and you had some questions
but that pre-training really helps a lot
uh and transfers very beneficially to
formal math and that's kind of the bulk
of that first paper and then
after the first paper you're like oh we
have a nice results we've shown that
language models can do some formal
mathematics uh but we were still
completely unable to prove olympia's
problems at all even the really easy
ones and so that really what we started
working on and there it's been a it's
been a also a long struggle i think
until uh we just decided to to bite the
bullets and and formalize
uh some some statements ourselves to
generate that curriculum that kind of a
really unlocked new capabilities and
let's do that to the work that we um
we've shared anything about the paper
that you want people to
um
to to get away or to take away with
maybe maybe you can look us a little bit
beyond math like you know what does what
does this tell us or anything you'd like
people to know
yeah i think so
the main takeaway i think i i want to
share is uh is why so
well we look at beyond mass but first
it's it's why formal mass is awesome
uh and uh i think we covered that uh
quite nicely but to me the main reasons
is that it's reasoning complete right if
you if you get a really impressive
result in form of mass you you're really
confident that you have a very
impressive result in reasoning
uh one other interesting aspects of it
is that it's uh inherently a safe setup
a lot of people are talking about safety
and that's kind of a last harbor where
we're not yet at all at human level yet
it's safe to try to push as hard as you
can because it's like games right you
are embedded in a formal system there is
no escape hatch
um
and finally
the the reason why i think it's so
exciting is because it lets you combine
a language model with a formal verifier
and so you're really getting the best of
both worlds you have language models
that are kind of
really impressive into what they can
generate but even gpt 3 if you give it a
few deductive steps it kind of falls off
really rapidly and so
they are capable of one-step reasoning
that are interesting but not multi-step
reasonings and so that's when you
tie it with a verifier that you can
basically
get the value of multi-step reasoning by
interacting with the verifier that is
here to verify the prediction and that's
i think what is really exciting here
the verifier kind of almost gives you
the
internal monologue that humans have when
they when they think
uh it's hard to imagine a language model
hearts during
the generation of one context size right
yet here we do have that that kind of
that kind of uh property which is a
which is exciting
and finally um the reason why i'm super
excited about them goes beyond mass in a
sense
i think and it's the reason why it's
it's really i mean
open eye is really a great place to work
on that because it's really aligned with
our mission and how we want to execute
it
the reason why is that if i if we i
think if we
if we crack formal mass
we really will be providing a blueprint
on how to infuse much more reasoning in
large informal language models and so i
really see it as kind of a
small experiment in shown experimental
lab where we can study reasoning when we
know that reasoning is kind of still
lacking in those very large language
models and so that's that's really that
that excites me and i think it will
transfer nicely you have formal maths
you have code generation in the middle
because you have unit tests but uh you
can't
be on unit test you cannot know for sure
that your program is correct and then
you have fully informal setups where you
just cannot verify well i think that
wraps it up pretty nicely
stan thank you very much for being here
this was really cool
[Music]
you